your life is dictated by the weight and  length  grains  seriously the pound was originally  defined by the weight of 7 000 grains  and the inch was originally defined by  the length of three barley corns placed  end to end who knows what a barley corn  is we still use it like we still I still  use that that's the thing I use what  happened well we know what happened we  know that the rest of the world got on  board with a system that was pegged to  the Earth and that was all multiplied by  10 and very logical and and just but  then three countries didn't and I've  been thinking about that a lot I made a  whole video diving way too deep into  this so you can go watch that but just  remember that if you live in the USA or  one of these other two countries